hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing
cakes cakes cakes
s5 cookie 5 whatever so
um c4 g6
probably a modern or a king zinnian
coming up
here black can play in a more offbeat
style yeah with moves like that or
or play um
knight f6 for the king's indian
queen b6 is what they normally do now
but you can also take on e2 form
a binoni
now in this benoni black is not unhappy
that one piece
is traded the knight is traded
it but it took um quite a good
amount of time so
it's um
strategically desirable for black but
also time consuming
okay i'm just taking here and playing a
simple position
what is that the decision f takes it's
not a move right
okay like hmm does he really want to
take with the pawn
that looks strange um i wanted to play
queen to d2
but maybe i should consider bishop f4
actually
now it's actually no reason to not to do
that actually
in many cases black can
drum up some play
to
to make a sacrifice out of this and
sacrifice the pawn but here that looked
really difficult to engineer
rook d a drop d1
and now
i could go knight d5 simply
more or less force him to take
still wonder if this is the best
solution
always have a somewhat soft spot for
bishop h6 in those positions somehow
this is a good piece on f4 but his
bishop is also
something that
also a good piece maybe this is not the
most forceful
way to play but i thought if i trade
those bishops play queen e3 and like
double on the d file that should be a
very
one-sided position his main goal
of counter play would be to somehow get
a knight to d4
but that looks difficult to accomplish
in this position i could have taken on
d6 but
that was not really something that i
wanted it
feels like um
i would have
given him far too much activity for
a silly pawn and the knight on e8 then
would be uh yeah gone quickly
so let's double now like this
b5 is not happening anytime soon
i don't see it at least how that could
happen
and i actually have f4 and so on so f4
come on
f4 f5 and so on just get this
roll in bishop g4
is an interesting move now actually
takes it and then i have knight d5
coming
it's not bad but you can also
go for this um
full scale expansion like this and g5
black is completely boxed in the only
active idea is b5 and
not not certain how this should be
happening
okay this is how it should happen he
says
b5 next and knight e6 coming but knight
e6 i have knight d5 so
this is not a thing
my my h4 g4 plan is
ambitious it wasn't the only
was not the only possible plan for sure
so how do we make more progress here
taking and then h5 or
yeah bishop g4
there is f5 potentially
you can also take and play e5 now right
as the this thing is unprotected
rook is unprotected
and here i can take d6 some or not
why do it or just take with the rook
this is a more
probably better
takes pawn takes
that's rook e8
but take with the rook i'm better but
i'm not winning
the time consideration is important here
didn't see knight e6 that f4 hangs
losing a little bit i'm losing control
of this position
94 maybe difficult
okay trading queens would be helpful
just for management purposes
so that i'm not getting mated or so
how is he not trading queens
queen h6 i have bishop g4
or maybe f5 even f5
f594 though okay
now b6 is just hanging for
pretty much nothing
and i don't see how he saves it so he
takes twice
knight d4 maybe
ah knight f5 ah yeah this is a way to
lose that game
by by blundering one movers
the whole game was so one-sided
but okay let's see
okay check check
e6 can we still play for win yeah i know
i only have 9 seconds but
knight g4 checking g493 king f6
okay
king g5 blundness the rook i saw that
now i can invade
not quite sure yet how to win it
i just want to gain a bit of time
and it's not totally obvious that it is
winning actually
king over to g5 looks right though
yeah it's probably not a win
oh check
yeah i have to decline the rematch
because of the analysis
i really want to figure this out what
happened here
so well a couple of things
um first of all
i want to briefly look at this like here
taking on
d6 is not a real option because
i thought you can just take everything
right take take
take take and then even this is a thing
but black can also just play this
position
the bishop here on g7 is so strong i
didn't see
b5 or anything just like it shouldn't
it shouldn't be um good anyway so
here the activity is compensating black
but i'm i'm pretty substantially better
here right
we need three knight f6 now doubling
like f4 it's like reasonable
and now we have to it's not
totally clear how to proceed so g4 is
one of the engine's top
moves it's it's definitely possible
it's just not so easy to do um with the
with the time constraints
because i'm opening up my my king
position
from a structural point of view this is
the ideal pawn structure here
and i would really embrace any end game
knight c7 oh it starts with
it started with 10 average sandy porn
loss but it will definitely go down
there have been blunders for sure at the
end of the game
so maybe somewhere before as well
okay now now i had e5 immediately yeah
that's that's
definitely definitely uh
possible and much easier to play this is
a thing
if um here
um like this this is just simple to play
and and crushing
so i took and played e5
oh rook h1 is just stronger
okay it doesn't why does that win
so completely
bishop g4
bishop g4 rook d8
f5 yeah
yeah hey it's very strong if you if you
are
a machine yeah rook d6 was
i my my clock was ticking down
i also thought that pawn takes could be
strong but rookie 8 was irritating and i
didn't see a great reply
queen g3 but if i take here with the
pawn i felt
it should be for an attack and i didn't
want to
trade the queens there but it's better
for white
okay i took with the rook rook takes
knight e6
95 rupees seven q3
please trade queens and here bishop g4
was
killing
yeah he definitely was back in the game
and then i even blundered knight f5 that
was
a big big big problem bishop g4 seems to
win as does
c takes a takes a5
yeah but that was like 10 seconds
territory
this is also why here i played this
ridiculous move now knight f5 is of
course
winning for black and now
it's it's it's back
back on trying to win and b4
before honestly i didn't even see that
it was hanging
and now i get to get some checks in
yeah here would have been interesting i
thought bishop g8 maybe but
it doesn't even help yeah has this check
yeah it's probably a draw e6 was a
try to win and he just gave up the
exchange there
um that should be a draw but of course
you can
you can try
here knight f8 instead of king f8
knight f8 knight h7 to
shield the pawns now i'm invading
and should probably win rook a6
rook h7 is a double question mark that's
uh harsh
that's harsh really
rook a8 because of what
zukswan
i see that this is a strong move because
he has to do this
and then i can also win that pawn
this this yeah but is that so bad
so knight g7
king e5 here
and that seems to still be a draw yeah
yeah i'm not not sure about it and i'm
not
i don't have any knowledge it's
something that
you can certainly study
yeah and here at
at the end i i i won this yeah with no
time on the clock that that's that's
probably still a draw
okay guys thanks for watching